>> Laura: WE HAVE TO ROLL.
WE HAVE TO GET KEVIN McCARTHY.
SPIRITED CONVERSATION, WE
APPRECIATE IT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS TEAM
LAID OUT A FAIRLY PAINSTAKING
DETAIL TODAY THEY’RE PREP FOR A
POSSIBLE VIRUS OUTBREAK IN THE
UNITED STATES.
THAT WAS NOT GOOD ENOUGH FOR THE
PARTY OF PAIN AND MISERY.
>> WHAT SHE IS DOING IS LATE,
TOO LATE.
HOPEFULLY WE CAN MAKE UP FOR THE
LOSS OF TIME.
>> CREATE A CZAR WHO KNOWS WHAT
HE IS DOING OR SHE IS DOING.
IT SHOULD BE A PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERT.
ASK FOR THE RIGHT AMOUNT OF
MONEY.
>> Laura: I AM BUYING HIM
BIFOCALS.
HOUSE MINORITY LEADER KEVIN
McCARTHY JOINS US.
CONGRESSMAN, THE RIGHT AMOUNT OF
MONEY TURNED OUT TO BE
$8.5 BILLION, SCHUMER SUGGESTED
IN A WRITTEN REQUEST THIS
MORNING.
ARE THEY JUST THROWING MONEY AT
THIS PROBLEM?
>> IT SEEMS LIKE SCHUMER IS JUST
PLAYING POLITICS.
WE HAD THE HEAD APPROPRIATIONS
BY REPUBLICANS OR DEMOCRATS TO
WALK THROUGH AND SEE WHAT WE
NEED?
THE PRESIDENT WAS OUT THERE
TODAY.
I’VE BEEN TO NUMEROUS MEETINGS
AT THE WHITE HOUSE, BICAMERAL,
BIPARTISAN, WALKING THROUGH LONG
BEFORE ANYBODY WAS TALKING ABOUT
THIS AND WE HAVE BEEN PREPARING
FOR THIS.
WHEN REPUBLICANS WERE THE
MAJORITY OF THE LAST FOUR OR
FIVE YEARS, WE’VE INCREASED NIH
AND CDC FUNDING ALMOST 40%.
YOU KNOW WE CREATED?
INFECTIOUS DISEASE RAPID
RESPONSE FUND P REPUBLICANS
CREATED THAT WONDERING IF THIS
DAY WOULD EVER COME.
SO WE HAVE BEEN PREPARING.
WE HAVE THE BEST HEALTH CARE IN
THE WORLD.
>> Laura: SHOULD THE MESSAGING
HAVE HIT SOONER?
SHOULD THIS PRESS CONFERENCE
HAVE HAPPENED THREE WEEKS AGO?
WOULD THAT HAVE GOTTEN --
ALL THE STUFF WAS IN PLACE
ALREADY BUT PEOPLE NEED TO HEAR
IT AND WHEN THEY HEAR IT THEY
SAY OKAY, NOW I GET IT.
>> YOU KNOW IT’S INTERESTING.
IF YOU ARE AN ELECTED OFFICIAL
YOU WILL GO TO YOUR FOURTH
MEETING ON THIS IN THE ENTIRE
CONGRESS.
EVERYBODY TOGETHER.
THEY HAVE BEEN HEARING ABOUT IT.
>> Laura: THEY WEREN’T TALKING
ABOUT IT UNTIL THIS WEEK.
AM I RIGHT OR WRONG?
THEY WEREN’T TALKING ABOUT IT IN
THESE FEVERISH TERMS.
>> THE DEMOCRATS WERE TALKING
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
THEY TRY TO CRITICIZE THE
PRESIDENT WHEN HE SHUT THE
PLANES DOWN FROM CHINA FROM
COMING INTO THE COUNTRY.
>> Laura: THAT’S MY POINT.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO GO FURTHER
THAN TRUMP.
>> ALL THEY ARE TRYING TO LOOK
AT.
THEY ARE ONE OF THOSE TEACHERS
THAT YOU HAVE THAT WANTS TO PUT
A RED MARK ON YOUR PAPER
INCIDENT TELLING WHAT YOU’RE
DOING RIGHT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN PREPARING
FOR THIS.
THE CHALLENGES WHAT DID CHINA
DO?
STARTED IN NOVEMBER AND THEY
NEVER TOLD US.
WE TRIED TO SEND SCIENTISTS AND
DOCTORS AND THEY WOULDN’T ALLOW
IT.
>> Laura: WAY TOO POSITIVE ON
PRESIDENT XI IN MY VIEW, AND HOW
HE’S HANDLED IT.
WE HAVE TO DO HAPPY TALK TO KEEP
CHINA DIPLOMACY GOING?
>> WE PUT OUR CDC AND CHINA
COPIED OUR CDC, CALL IT THAT,
BETWEEN OUR SCIENTIST THEY
WORK TOGETHER.
IT’S A LEADERSHIP AND I THINK
WHAT XI HAS BEEN DOING IS TRYING
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE MEDIA IS
PUSHED DOWN INSTEAD OF SPENDING
THE TIME --
YOU CAN’T BELIEVE ANY NUMBERS.
>> Laura: IT COULD BE BIGGER
THAN WHAT THEY ARE SAYING.
>> THE CONCERN IS WHAT IT GOES
TO OTHER PLACES, THAT’S BECOME A
>> Laura: THE PRESIDENT RIDING
HIGH AFTER A FAILED IMPEACHMENT
CONVICTION, MUELLER BOMB.
THEY SAID A RECESSION WAS GOING
TO HAPPEN.
NOTHING HAPPENED.
THE ECONOMY VITALS ARE VERY
STRONG.
DO DEMOCRATS SEE IT AS THEIR
OPPORTUNITY, THEIR HECK OF A JOB
BROWNIE MOMENT?
THEIR MOMENT TO SAY AHA.
>> THEY WOULD SEIZE ANY MOMENT.
COMPARE THIS WHEN EBOLA WAS HERE
IN PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS IN
OFFICE.
YOU HAVE REPUBLICAN MAJORITY
WORKING TOGETHER, NOT PLAYING
POLITICS.
THESE ARE -- THIS IS PEOPLE’S
HEALTH.
IT’S NOT THE TIME TO PLAY
POLITICS.
SCHUMER WENT OUT AND PICKED A
NUMBER OUT OF THE AIR JUST TO
TRY TO GO AFTER THE PRESIDENT
AND FOR NANCY PELOSI TO SAY THAT
AFTER THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
PREPARING FOR THIS, THEY ARE
TRYING TO GET --
>> Laura: HAS SHE BEEN TALKING
TO THE PRESIDENT ABOUT THIS ONE
THIS ONE-ON-ONE?
>> I DON’T -- YOU’D HAVE TO ASK
THE PRESIDENT.
WE HAD THE ADMINISTRATION GIVING
US BRIEFINGS.
WE ARE GOING INTO OUR FOURTH ONE
THIS WEEK.
>> Laura: I HAD TO GET YOUR
REACTION TO LAST NIGHT’S DEBATE.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE EMPLOYING NO
NEW TALKING POINT AGAINST BERNIE
AND ONE OF THEM EVEN TAKES A
SHOT AT YOU.
WATCH.
>> IT ADDS UP TO FOUR MORE YEARS
OF DONALD TRUMP, KEVIN
McCARTHY A SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE AND THE INABILITY TO GET
THE SENATE INTO DEMOCRATIC
HANDS.
THE TIME HAS COME FOR US TO STOP
ACTING LIKE THE PRESIDENCY IS
THE ONLY OFFICE THAT MATTERS.
>> Laura: "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
ACTUALLY ASKED SPEAKER PELOSI
ABOUT THIS TODAY AND HERE’S WHAT
SHE TOLD THEM.
ARE YOU COMFORTABLE WITH
BERNIE SANDERS THE TOP OF THE
TICKET?
PELOSI SAID YEAH.
REPORTER SAID YOU WERE HE WILL
JEOPARDIZE YOUR MAJORITY?
PELOSI SAYS NO.
CONGRESSMAN, SHOULD SHE BE
WORRIED?
>> SHE SHOULD BE WORRIED BECAUSE
WHAT THEY HAVE DONE IN CONGRESS
IS LITERALLY NOTHING AND THEY
SHOULD BE WORRIED ABOUT ALL THE
SUCCESS THE PRESIDENT HAS.
SHE’S NOT WORRIED ABOUT
BERNIE SANDERS BECAUSE SHE’S
ALREADY SURRENDERED TO THE
SOCIALISTS.
MORE THAN HALF OF THEM HAVE THE
WAS PONDERED MEDICARE FOR ALL.
THIS IS A PARTY THAT
THIS IS A PARTY THAT WOULD
RATHER COMMEND COMMUNISM THEN
DEFEND DEMOCRACY.
>> Laura: LAST YEAR WHEN THE
PRESIDENT SAID WE WILL NEVER BE
A SOCIALIST COUNTRY.
YOU STOOD UP.
THE DEMOCRATS WERE LIKE, I’M NOT
SURE IF I SHOULD SIT OR STAND.
[LAUGHS]
>> WE ONLY NEED 18 SEATS WITH A
MAJORITY SO THE ANSWER IS YES.
THEY WANT TO FIND -- WE HAVE
SOME OF THE BEST EVER.
>> Laura: YOU HAVE A BIG
RECRUIT CLASS.
>> WE NEED TO TAKE THE